hey there bioneers thanks for tuning in
and welcome back to my kitchen
so i just uploaded a video on the
nootropic breakfast as i call it which
is the ideal breakfast for boosting your
brain power and productivity
throughout the day ahead now i'm going
to show you the anabolic breakfast this
is a breakfast designed
to put your body in an anabolic mode for
burning fat and building muscle
i got the ideas mainly from the 4-hour
body a book by tim ferriss which i
highly recommend really enjoy
but i'm going to share it with you here
because i do a few things differently
and perhaps there's some bodybuilders
out there who haven't seen this
it's an ideal uh breakfast if someone's
cutting
or if you want to just put on lean mass
and
it's also a very healthy and tasty one
for anyone else who just wants a healthy
breakfast to start their day with
so without further ado let's get going
okay so what you will need is eggs
spinach i buy it frozen because it's
highly practical
it's just as healthy it contains all the
same nutrients you can just bung it in
the freezer
and as you'll see it's very quick and
easy to prepare and
salt and pepper because you want it to
taste nice
okay so to begin what you're going to do
is take your bowl
and crack into it one
or two eggs i recommend at least
two get full benefits
then you're gonna add just a little bit
of water just a small amount
then you're gonna whack it in the
microwave
and cook it on full power i'm going for
two minutes
i like my nice and hard oil you can try
it in all different ways you know
mess around with different times in the
microwave and different temperatures to
get
just the consistency you like so why are
we having eggs well first of all of
course
eggs are a fantastic source of protein
they contain all of the essential amino
acids they're one of the only food
sources that does this because you're
essentially eating everything you need
to build a whole animal
so that way you provide your body with
all the building blocks for building
muscle and all the other tissue
when you're awake your body is mostly in
a metabolic state in its
catabolic state meaning it's burning fat
rather than building muscle
but uh it still does do some repairs you
need to make sure that you have a good
supply of protein before you start your
day
it's good for your brain as well perhaps
more importantly though eggs have been
shown to also help you burn fat
as has any source of protein when taken
first thing in the morning within the
first half an hour to an hour
of waking up studies have shown that
simply
having some kind of protein source like
this in the morning can help you to lose
weight throughout the day
even with no other changes to your diet
or your routine that's because it helps
to boost your resting
metabolic rate so that your body is
burning fat more throughout the whole
rest of the day
so you're giving your body all of the
materials it needs for building muscle
whilst also telling it to burn
fat at the same time eggs contain
cholesterol
which in this case is actually good for
us because it's what testosterone is
made out of
take that out and put it to one side
you've now got your
nicely poached legs
next up the spinach spinach
is high in iron as you know although not
as high as
researchers that's a little bit much
but never mind let's go with it it's not
as high in iron as
um scientists once believed because
famously uh they originally put the
decimal point
in the wrong place but it is still high
nine even divided by ten
and this makes it very good for making
sure that
oxygen gets around the body providing
you with lots of
energy and also endurance in the gym and
as you're probably gonna be working out
today i hope spinach is also a great
source of slow-release carbs meaning
it'll provide energy gradually
throughout the day
thus preventing you from snacking eggs
are also one of the best appetite
suppressants when eating first thing in
the morning so it's yet another reason
this is such a
great anabolic breakfast on top of this
spinach has also been shown to boost
glucose metabolism
which means it can once again help with
fat burning and weight loss
so all in all you get tons of amino
acids phytoactive steroids to help you
build more muscle
you get increased metabolism throughout
the day
you get extra glucose metabolism and you
have a slow release of energy
and your appetite suppress whilst that
sorts itself out
let's prepare the plate which you also
need i also didn't mention the plate
play prepared do some washing up
you could uh call your mum
as i said in my nootropic breakfast
video i also like to supplement
with odorless garlic which is fantastic
for fat burning and has again been shown
in many studies
to uh improve weight loss
and at the same time it's a vasodilator
for bodybuilders watching this
that's the same as nitric oxide in other
words it will widen your blood vessels
so that more
uh nutrients and oxygen and iron which
we're getting from the spinach
can get around your body providing you
with energy muscle building properties
etc nearly there now
but in reality i would be doing my
hair or whatever at this point not just
standing and staring at the microwave
if you ever want to microwave two things
in the microwave at once get two bowls
put a plate in between stand the next
bowl on top
pro tip for you there
and before you know it the spinach is
ready so there we go that's now going to
form the nice
carb base of my meal the filling and
satisfying bit
there's still a little bit of water
around the edge of my eggs
so i'm going to get them out
good organizations i'm gonna get them
out with this spooner
yeah i mean admittedly
i've left mine in a little bit too long
nice to have them running
there you go that combination is
actually tastier than you might think
to look at it add a little bit of pepper
little bit of salt
and chow down of course this is going to
be boiling hot
for the purpose of
the video i'm going to now try it and
say um whilst pretending my mouth's not
burning
it's tastier than you think so there you
have it the perfect
anabolic breakfast that you can do in
eight minutes that will help you to burn
fat and build muscle throughout the day
also has a lot of other health benefits
so enjoy thanks for watching stay tuned
for the next one
haha so hot